in terms of the music ham just like use
the title track and I was looking at
some of the YouTube comments a lot of
people are kind of taking this as a gay
anthem like kind of you know inclusive
inclusivity yeah I with the pride
community like it was that what the song
was originally intended for I don't the
song originally was a song about drugs
it was a song about well it wasn't just
about drugs it was about their really it
was actually about like our friends and
this idea of like you know we had found
a community of like-minded alternative
kids kids who were required some work
we're some who were alternative some who
were you know going to raves listening
to the kinds of music that we were
listening to and I the song I think was
written as a sort of anthem for our
little group of friends it was sort of
this song about like you know together
we can sort of take on the world but
there was also this you know the chorus
we've sort of augmented it slightly but
the original chorus was sort of like
this is about like having these wild
mind opening kind of experience like
we're messed up we're disconnected we're
all you have lost but together together
we can do anything yeah I know I felt
very meaningful but I do like it as a
PSA again we are not encouraging this
this drug is we are admitting it
happened in the 1990s but what I will
say is that I I've also seen that people
are sort of adopting this the title of
the album and the title of this song you
know talking about the LGBTQ community I
love that I think it's a really
wonderful example of a song that doesn't
have to be able to love it doesn't have
to be about a romantic relationship
it is about community and connection and
this idea that even though those of us
who feel that we are isolated alone
there's no one like us in the world who
gets us I think there is and I think
like this idea that music can make us
feel that even even just by listening to
a song or reading some comments you can
feel a little less alone in the world
like that's beautiful to me and so I
love that people are sort of like adding
that narrative to it I think it's cool
do you think being out in the music
industry has changed over the last ten
years like I don't know if you saw the
clip of a little nas X talking a few
weeks about you know why you wanted to
come over he's at the top of the charts
like do you think it's changed a little
bit that it's easier I think it has
changed tremendously I think it's
difficult in some ways still and
and and so much better in other ways I
think there's new things that come up
and I think that the reality is is that
it's always probably going to be a
little difficult and a little hard it's
also hard to assign a value to like like
you couldn't can't really comb through
our career and be like there it is there
it is there was the homophobia that held
Tegan and Sara back you know it's not so
it's not so protester or obvious it was
slight slightly more subtle than that
but but it adds up so but yes I think
there's been tremendous change in our
industry and in the world but you can't
legislate away ignorant and hate and
homophobia and when you couple that with
misogyny it's complicated and our
industry is still you know predominantly
run and dominated by whites as hetero
men and when you look at the pop charts
there are still very few women that look
like us there are very few women that
are identified openly as LGBTQ I think
streaming has changed that I think
streaming has exploded our industry into
a million little pieces and you can
thrive in so many pockets without the
mainstream and that has been a bigger
change I don't know that the collective
worldview of LGBTQ people has changed
that dramatically but the pockets in
which you can thrive have become plenty
and I think you just have to be able to
find them you have to find your nation
you can you can thrive and the list of
LGBTQ artists that are thriving from you
know the King princess to you know like
so many of the amazing artists I always
want to pick the ones that have gotten
to radio like other choice like a Halsey
or a choice around like or a Sam Smith
these are branding her loyal friend yeah
these are profound but the underground
scene in some of these smaller pockets
it's incredible what's happening and I'm
just thrilled I'm thrilled to see how it
continues to evolve and change my one
baked my PSA on that though is is that I
don't think that we should celebrate our
LGBTQ artist into a pocket let
themselves learn and I think that we
need to be careful that when we're
giving space that LGBTQ people that
we're not giving them a space where only
LGBTQ people celebrated didn't thrive in
the known the LGBTQ people go when Sarah
and I cracked the mainstream with closer
and heartthrob our record you know six
years ago it was incredible to see
the young kids and the young people that
flooded to us from the mainstream who
were LGBTQ identified and they were
thrilled to have us and and so we have
to remember that like we it's like we're
not we don't have to flourish only in
the nice world like we can flourish out
anywhere so you know that's my only
thing as I think there's lots of change
but let's make sure it trickles down
let's see representation everywhere not
just you know one person on the charts
and then we're like claps everybody we
got one gay person so we've definitely
changed this is Sami homophobia that's
affecting you know like it's not it's
you know we just you know we're still
there we're still talking about it would
you know this Philip Roth absolutely
well said I mean I don't know I can't
throw everything exhausting yeah